all right Decatur Illinois is next
ginnis up hi Jenni how are you hi Dave
I'm wonderful how are you better than I
deserve what's up I well another
question for you Dave I retired from a
major company after 27 years and we were
debt free completely house and all we've
been good savers we've got about
three-quarters of a million saved my
husband hired 58 I went back to work
after five months because I found that
my pension just wasn't enough to get
through the monthly bills um you know
just doctor's bills and cable and that
kind of junk how much it'll answer it's
only $1,300 a month so it's very
pathetic what about your husband well
he's still working and he is still the
mind that most of his money goes to
we're still saving in the saving mode so
what are you learning oh uh he makes
about 60,000 a year so yeah I live on
60,000 a year plus 1,300 oh sure we
could well he puts everything at $250 a
week into saving the mother he needs to
change that well I understand that I
know that he I aren't quite on that same
page but that's a battle but I can't
fight right now so my question is should
i I'm miserable in this job that I took
I feel like my life is just really
passing me by doing something I don't
like you have 7 or $50,000 in the bank
you're 58 years old you have a $60,000
well now you have an $80,000 household
income right now right all right not
counting your job and you have no debt
whatsoever anywhere in the world I don't
know why you work but how do I convince
him that we can start taking a little
bit out of our I think you have to take
anything out I think you have to quit
putting so that gun much in that you
can't eat I don't know I'm not
suggesting anything out of 750 but you
ought to be able to live on
80,000 dollars a year with no debt we
absolutely could how do I explain to him
that he can stop saving that money and
we can live on it now you're gonna let
him live and you're gonna let him live
you're not gonna kill him now he's gonna
kill me no absolutely serious this is
ludicrous that your husband has cracked
the whip and pushed you with this false
set of economics into a job you hate
when you guys are financially
independent he should love his wife
better than that I wouldn't do that to
Sharron and she wouldn't do that to me
wouldn't let it happen either one of us
and this is a marriage problem what's
your job this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
you